-Jimmy, show's about to start.
You ready?
-Ooh, not only am I ready,
I am freaking out!
-Yeah, it should be pretty good.
-Ralph Macchio, Jennifer Beals,
Lea Thompson,
music from Modern English.
This is gonna be the best
'80s show ever!
-All right, all right, Jimmy.
You're getting a little crazy.
-Not only am I '80s crazy,
I'm a maniac.
[ "Maniac" plays ]
-Oh, no.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Just a steel-town girl
on a Saturday night ♪
♪ Lookin' for
the fight of her life ♪
♪ In the real time world,
no one sees her at all ♪
♪ They all say she's crazy ♪
♪ It can cut you like a knife ♪
♪ If the gift
becomes the fire ♪
♪ On a wire between
will and what will be ♪
♪ She's a maniac,
maniac on the floor ♪
♪♪
♪ And she's dancing like -- ♪♪
[ "Old Time Rock & Roll" plays ]
Whoa, whoa.
Higgins, shirt's a little short,
but, overall,
pretty good for the '80s show.
-Oh, we're doing an '80s show?
I better get dressed.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ She's a maniac,
maniac on the floor ♪
♪♪
♪ And she's dancing
like she's never danced ♪
♪ Dancing like
she's never danced ♪
she's never danced before ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]